what's uh through all your explorations
of quantum Computing what's the coolest
most
beautiful idea that you've come across
that has been solved or has not yet been
solved I think the journey to understand
something called ads CFT so the journey
to understand quantum gravity through
this picture where a hologram of lesser
Dimension is actually dual or exactly
corresponding to a bulk uh theory of
quantum gravity of an extra Dimension
and the fact that this sort of
Duality comes from trying to
learn deep learning like representations
of the
boundary and so at least part of my
journey someday uh on my bucket list is
to apply Quantum machine Lear learning
to uh these sorts of systems these cfts
or uh they're called syk models um and
learn an emergent geometry from from the
boundary Theory and so we can have a
form of machine
learning helps us to help
us understand quantum gravity right
which is you know still a holy grill
that I would like to hit before I leave
this
earth what do you think is going on with
black holes as
information
storing and processing units what do you
think is going on with black holes black
holes are really fascinating objects
they're at the inter interface between
quantum mechanics and gravity and so
they help us test all sorts of ideas um
I think that you know for many decades
now there's been sort of this black hole
information Paradox that things that
fall into the black hole seem to we've
seem to have lost their
information now I think there's this uh
firewall Paradox that has been allegedly
resolved in recent years by um you know
a former peer of mine uh who's now
professor at Berkeley um and uh there it
seems like there's as information falls
into a black hole it's sort of there's
sort of a sedimentation right as you as
you get closer and closer to the Horizon
from the point of view of the Observer
on the outside the object slows down
infinitely as it gets closer and closer
and so everything that is falling to a
black hole from our perspective gets
sort of sedimented and tacked on to the
near Horizon and at some point it gets
so close to the Horizon it's
in the proximity or the scale which in
which Quantum effects and Quantum
fluctuations matter and
there some that in Falling matter could
interfere with sort of the traditional
pictures that it could interfere with
the creation and annihilation of
particles and antiparticles in the
vacuum and through this
interference uh one of the particles
gets entangled with the infalling
information and one of them is now free
and escapes and that's how there's sort
of mutual information between the
outgoing radiation and the infall matter
uh but getting that calculation right I
think we're only just starting to uh put
the pieces together um there's a few
pothead like questions I want to ask you
sure so one does it terrify you that
there's a giant black hole at the center
of our galaxy I don't know I I I just
want to you know set up shop near it to
to fast forward you know meet the meet a
future civilization right like if we
have a limited lifetime if you could go
orbit a black hole and emerge uh so if
you were like if there was a special
mission that could take you to a black
hole would you volunteer to go travel to
orbit and not obviously not fall into it
that's obvious so it's obvious to you
that everything's destroyed inside a
black hole like all the information they
makes up Gom is destroyed um maybe on
the other side bef jil's emerg and it's
all like is tied together in some deeply
mul way yeah I mean that's a great
question we we have to
answer what black holes are are they are
we punching a hole through SpaceTime and
creating a pocket Universe it's possible
right then then that would mean that if
we Ascend the cter chef scale to you
know beyond CF type 3 we could engineer
black holes with specific
hyperparameters to transmit information
to new universes we create and so we can
have progyny right uh that are new
universes and so so we even though our
universe may reach a heat death we may
have a way to have a legacy right so we
don't know yet we need to ascend The
Carter shf scale to answer these
questions right to peer into that regime
of higher energy physics and maybe you
can uh speak to the CF scale for people
who don't know so one one of the uh sort
of mem likee principles and goals
of uh the eak movement is to ascend the
CF scale what is the CF scale and when
do we want to ascend it the carf scale
is a measure of our energy production
and
consumption um and really it's a
logarithmic scale and CEF type one is a
milestone where we are producing the
equivalent wattage to all the energy
that is incident on earth from the sun C
Chef type two would be harnessing all
the energy that is output by the Sun and
I think type three is like the whole
galaxy I think level yeah yeah yeah and
then some people have some crazy type
four and five but I don't know if I
believe in those but um to me it seems
like from the first principles of
thermodynamics that again this there's
this concept of
thermodynamic uh driven dissipative
adaptation
where you know life evolved on Earth
because we have this sort of energetic
drive from the sun right we have
incident energy and life evolved on
Earth to
capture figure out ways to best capture
that free energy to maintain itself and
and grow and I think that that principle
it's not special to our Earth Sun System
we can extend life well beyond and we
kind of have a respon ability to do so
because that's the process that brought
us here so we don't even know what it
has in store for us in the future it
could be something of beauty we can't
even imagine today
right